if nicole n to be us we're going to
present the real-time monitoring for
distributed systems and thank you I hope
everybody had a good lunch and I'm nakul
and together with Tobias every from a
trade mob to mob is a berlin-based
startup and today we're going to be
talking about how we do monitor our
systems in real time just to give you a
bit of context Chad mob is a mobile app
marketing platform we do things like
user acquisition for apps and we also do
retargeting and we're among the largest
their mobile these demand-side platforms
in the real-time bidding ecosystem the
talk will be actually split into two
parts I will give an introduction to the
engineering aspect of how we do
monitoring and this will be followed by
Tobias talking about the techniques and
algorithms that we use in how we do
things as a demand-side platform and you
can imagine in the real-time bidding
ecosystem we are dealing with anywhere
between 10,000 requests per second to
100 or 150 thousand requests per second
on any given day this means that our
infrastructure has to actually
organically scale based on the traffic
that we are receiving now we believe
that at no matter what scale you are
it's very important to measure anything
and measure everything metrics give us
an insight and an overview into the
systems which lets us improve our mean
response to detect and to also respond
to these issues not to mention we get an
operational over you at different levels
of granularity however at the scale that
we are working it we range from anywhere
between a hundred servers on a given day
to 500 or plus servers at this scale the
number of metrics the sheer amount of
data that you're collecting becomes
overwhelming you cannot expect to have
dashboards and have expect developers to
be looking at these dashboards and come
to conclusive decisions that actually
help in how you are dealing with the
metrics that you're collecting
now while we are facing this problem one
there was a 10 trending topic that came
up in the ecosystem and the community
companies like Twitter and Etsy they've
been pushing to something less anomaly
detection or outlier detection which is
quite popular in a lot of telemetry data
now we thought this is a good idea we
could detect anomalies in our
applications and our infrastructure and
actually it reacted to these issues but
when we actually put it into production
and we observed that this was actually
not really useful just itself because
the number of false positives that we
got with anomaly detection was fairly
high and we ended up going from we ended
up actually doubling the number of
alerts we would get from the infra
structure on the monitoring stack that
we had now at this point we said okay
this is not clearly working for us we
need something smarter which means we
would have to put in more machine
learning on top of this so we thought
some other ideas such as seasonality or
converging across mapping could be a lot
interesting for us so when we combine
the signals from different algorithms on
top of her metric data we could actually
come to conclusive decision-making based
on the signals that we are getting from
this so to sum it up anomaly detection
itself is an extension to your toolkit
and it alone cannot give you conclusive
evidence to make your decision and react
to events in your infrastructure however
we another problem that we had at this
point was there wasn't a single piece of
software or system that could actually
enable us to do all of this in rather
easily and abstracted this against our
developers and in terms of operations as
well so we decided that we need to build
something for this but to do this we had
a set of clear requirements among them
where this had to be neat real time or
at least near real-time why i say near
real-time is because when you're
collecting metrics data across your
stack it flows through different
aggregation policies so if you're using
something that is popular in your like
stats tea or carbon
these metrics flow down to your final
end of the funnel at different levels of
interval could be one second or ten
seconds so it's almost real time and but
it doesn't necessarily have to mean that
it is not real time at all we also
needed isolation so if you're applying
different algorithms on top of the same
telemetry data this means that we have
to have enabled these algorithms to run
independently and in a non-blocking way
against each other so that we can decide
based on the evidence that we can get
from the data besides this it had to
have a really low footprint so if you're
trying to optimize your infrastructure
and your performance based on the number
of instances you're running you cannot
expect to have a system that can
actually that actually takes up a lot of
resources this moment metrics are
monitoring system has to have a really
low footprint so that you can actually
optimize on your cost and it had to be
extensible what I mean about
extensibility here is in terms of the
algorithms itself it had to be really
easy for us to plug in new algorithms
and new ways of looking at the data and
also the data sources themselves had to
be really extensible with interfaces so
we went about building em system called
animali animali is basically a system to
gather metrics selectively and then
apply analysis on them and this is all
abstract from the developers into
operations so that it's fairly easier to
set it up now this has been used a trade
mob extensively to actually optimize our
cost at an infrastructure level by
monitoring the performance and it has
also helped in bringing down the number
of alerts that we would normally get but
before we could actually put into
production we had to do something that
was very important we have to scope the
metrics now we are talking about metrics
there are basically two levels of
metrics that you normally collect one is
application metrics themselves which
come down from your services like how
many requests am i doing on a given
second what is the latency for each
request and so on and the second would
be your system level metrics what is my
cpu look like
what ask what is the amount of memory
that I'm consuming and so on now by
scoping what I mean is we needed to look
at this metrics at different levels of
granularity we wanted to know how much
CPU we were consuming as a whole service
itself but also a different levels of
clusters say if you are dealing with
auto scaling groups you want to know how
much CPU is this auto scaling group
consuming as a unit how much of memory
are we consuming globally in a given
region now when we compete when we take
this different levels of granularity we
can then use this data to come to better
decision-making I can give you a simple
example on this a simple metric that we
have basically looks somewhat like this
you have host you have the the region
that it is coming from the availability
zone if it applies the auto scaling
group and the particular tag of the
service itself basically each one of
these is a tag that is separated by a
colon now when we actually multiplex
this would actually eel a number of
combinations that actually make sense we
get metrics at different levels of
granularity this would then have to be
passed into different levels of
aggregation so that you can get more
evidence and compare this data to
actually at different possible levels to
actually summarize this is what our tech
stack looks like when we collect the
metrics and monitor them we have a bunch
of services at the top that are all
sending the data to a multiplexer or an
aggregator where the data is then
multiplexed aggregated at different
interval levels of period and then it is
pushed to a layer called collecting now
the collected demon is a lib UV based
Python implementation that is basically
a server that just lets you selectively
collect data that your operations team
or your developers are interested in and
this is further then pushed down to a
metric store layer the magic store could
be any generic key value storage or a
database depending on what you are using
your technical stack now once the
algorithms are actually pushed into the
system there's a task runner that is
capable of
periodically running these algorithms
against the data from the metrics store
and it then triggers events these events
are then fed into an external system
which is capable of triggering actions
these actions could be such as if the
algorithm determines that one instance
or one server of yours is not performing
optimally then you can decide to kill
this instance since you're in it in an
infrastructure level you're performing
at an auto scaling group which means
that okay you can choose to kill this
instance or you can choose to restart a
service or so on so what animali
actually provides us is a frame more of
a framework that lets as push the data
into the system and have different
algorithms look at it in different
perspectives now Tobias will give you
more insight and to the math and the
science behind the algorithms themselves
that we use to do this yeah thanks on
cool I'm going to present the a group
make part of animali and first of all I
would like to start with a short
introduction how anomalies could look
like and what possible ways there are to
react on them so the first example is
rather simple it just shows the CPU
utilization of a single box which
suddenly peaks at one hundred percent
and because you can catch this by just
applying a static threshold and if this
gets exceeded you can react on it the
second example also shows cpu
utilization in this case it looks rather
stable at first glance it doesn't look
so if you put this into a context this
means the green it's supposed to be
green area define something like an
expected state of of the box and yeah
obviously the given box is not into this
area so you could also say after a
certain period of time that this is
misbehaving in some way and the third
example is a time series plot of
incoming system metrics and we see you
three consecutive days in here and I
guess it's also obvious that we had some
issues at the question he is
what kind of a great them is applicable
to to find those outages and yeah if we
wrap this up and it all comes down to
the point that before you can do proper
anomaly detection you need a way of
defining what you expect from your
system or from your service and only
then you can really define some
situations as okay or as false in the
end and in the following I would like to
go into two directions the first one is
the behavior of the distributed system
so as nakul mentioned we have couple of
distributed services which sometimes
contains up to hundreds of boxes and now
the question is how do single boxes
behave within such such a group and one
way of doing this is so called tackies
outlier filter so what we see here is a
snapshot of CPU value so it goes from 0
to 100 and each blue dot is just
representing one box with the CPU where
you at this time and what we see it's
quite dense between around fifty and
sixty percent but there are also some
boxes which are much below that or much
above it and one way of judging this is
using quantized so what we see here is
the quantile 25 so just cut off between
the lower 25% to this upper 75% of the
values of this distribution and
accordingly the quantized 75 and if you
take the difference of those two values
to get the so-called interquartile range
which just gives you kind of a robust
statistics for the middle fifty percent
of values and you should now multiply
this value by a constant and add it up
to the quantized 75 or subtracted from
the quanta 25 you get the screen band
and in this case we would define this as
unhealthy state or as an expected
behavior of the service group and every
box which is not within that would then
be defined as an outlier of course this
is only an episode we are handing time
series data so in practice it looks more
like this so we have a couple of metrics
plotted here and we have again this this
green band which is exactly the same
like on the Left plot and
this one box which is running only at
around ten percent of CPU so basically
we are losing money at this point of
time because it's not consuming what it
could use and you can now set thresholds
like if this happens for more than one
hour to hour whatever and then you can
react on it like restart the service on
the box or even kill the box and just
put up another one quick summary of this
so the idea is that we want to identify
auto scaling issues it's not only about
CPU usage it's also about memory leaks
or you can also think about business
kpi's like requests of a single box
compared to the others the restriction
years of course that you always need a
healthy range so if all your boxes to
misbehave you would still define this
interquartile range and would still
define a healthy range even though your
whole service has problems at this
moment and that leads us to the second
part which is the performance of the
overall systems or one last word to CPU
if we think about a service consisting
of couple of machines you can touch this
also by just taking the average cpu
utilization and if this metric has
issues of course you have a bunch of
bigger problem than just a single box
which which is misbehaving in this case
and well there are a couple of
algorithms how to tackle this and what
we are currently using a so-called
seasonal trend decomposition algorithm
we see your time series plot of seven
consecutive days and I guess it's quite
obvious that there is a given
seasonality so most of our metrics have
this seasonality of one day so we see
more or less the same pattern day by day
and the algorithm is exactly using this
so it's taking this as an input and it's
generating two components of this time
series namely the seasonal part and the
trend part so seasonal we see it it's
small as identical over the seven days
and the trend component is able to catch
things like if you have a constant
increase of traffic for instance
it would be reflected in here what we
see in this example that it's rather
stable in the beginning and it has a
slight increase during the end of the
metric and that is for a good reason
because if you look at the days you can
find the weekend in there so Saturday
Sunday usually have more traffic and
this in this case gets just reflected by
it by the trend component how do we do
that or how do we use it to find
anomalies another example for that so we
see two days here for incoming traffic
and okay we also see the outages already
here but one way of doing it is now to
apply the algorithm to create seasonal
and Trent part and you can now just add
them up so if you add the two time
series up you get kind of a model of
your service so this is exactly what you
would expect from this service by just
using historic data of course we are not
looking at only two days we look back up
to a 14 or even 28 days to reconstruct
this and with this model you can just
combine it with the raw input and take
the difference and of course then it's
quite obvious so we have the deviation
distribution now and with the proper
threshold it's quite easy to catch door
through outages unfortunately it doesn't
look that nice all the times or error
distributions look more like this or
even worse so we have Peaks we have
drops and the question of course is when
do you want to react so what is this
threshold or state where you would say
okay there probably is an issue and of
course you always want to have a very
low number of false positive but you
also don't want to miss really problems
and that is a big part of the whole
problem so the algorithm is producing
this error distribution but to really
get the information out of it is you're
not that easy and often quite specific
for for specific metrics also i just put
in here some ways how you can act on it
one is normalization there's some
minimum deviations before you want
even start alerting or reacting on it
there are static thresholds which are a
bit complicated because you need to know
beforehand what kind of deviation you
would allow expect and the way we are
usually going dynamic thresholds where
you can just set up something like a 99
dot 9th want I'll and if we're use are
Baptists you react on it and if you
apply this or combinations of this then
the output looks like this so we have
just a flag now which indicates if
everything is fine or if we are in a
narrow state and pending on the length
of such a narrow state we can take
actions like restarting services or of
course learning people because in
overall performance metrics there
usually are bigger issues who has have
to be investigated further and for now
let's all about animali itself the last
part is going to be about dynamic
threshold so how do we estimate those
ones and what we use for this is the
data structure called t digest it's
originally implemented and I guess
invented by Ted Dunning and the problem
is that if you have a lot of real
numbers and that's exactly what those
error distributions reflect then of
course you can do the lossless approach
you can store all those values you can
order them and calculate the quantized
but you can do smarter and that's
exactly what T digest is about it's
basically an online clustering of real
number values and it has the purpose to
create rank pay statistics such as
quantez and by doing this it's quite
fast and memory efficient and what's
very important for us is that it has a
very high accuracy for especially
extreme quantized so in the very low end
and high end and that's usually things
where we are looking at of course I
would now like to go through a bit the
algorithm just to give a rough idea how
this is working
the key concept or the key element of a
tea digest is a so-called central source
android has a mean value we will see
that on the x axis afterwards it has a
capacity which is yeah well it's its
capacity and it has a count which
basically reflects the number of
elements we already added to this
centroid and the the example now is just
a stream of 10 real values and yeah we
want to add them now one more words to
the centroids so at the ideas that you
keep an ordered list of such centroids
and always when you want to add a new
value you use search for the closest
centroid and if this centroid has enough
capacity you add value to it otherwise
you create a new centroid and yeah let's
just go through through the numbers and
of course in the beginning there is no
centroid yet so we just create one yeah
sorry yeah we'll come to that in a
second term yeah um so the first
centroid is the mean value minor 3.58
and it has a count of one because it's
just one element and in the beginning it
also has a capacity of one so that's
just our first centroid and if we now
move on and add the second element which
is 3.77 again the the algorithm tries to
find the closest Android which is the
only one which sexists right now but the
capacity is at one so we cannot add a
new element with a count of one that's
why we have to create a new centroid
object here which looks like that and
the same happens for the third number so
minus fifteen dot 26 if we add it we
would try or we try to find the closest
one which is here the left one but it
still has a limited capacity so it's not
able to get a new value so we create a
third centroid and now something
interesting happens and that's many did
the idea behind T digest so the the
capacity of the
Android's change over time so they can't
get constantly re-evaluated after
inserting a new element and yeah we are
now in the situation that we can add a
new element which is minus 1.8 ooh we
find the closest centroid which is
exactly this middle centroid and this
one has now a capacity they got into so
it has enough room to to add one new
element and this is exactly what happens
now so okay I go sorry right so this is
the closest element and if we add this
and this happens so we see two things
one is that the small blue dot sorry oh
sorry so here we see the count increases
to 22 and also the mean shift so we have
a slight shift to the value minus 1.8 2
and yeah that's the idea and that is how
you build up a structure like T digest
and I don't want to go through all the
details all the numbers now but yeah if
you add all the numbers you for ten
numbers at least you end up with
something like this what we can also see
here is that we have 10 real numbers but
we also only have eight centroids so we
also have kind of a reduced number of
elements and this guy is quite well over
time and the next slide is coming back
to your question also of course I'd the
question now is how is this capacity
thing you're working and the idea of a
centroid is the following so it has a
capacity which is proportional to affect
or delta which is namely a free
parameter which you can set and you
don't you do not set exactly the number
of elements you want to add but this is
like a trade-off between storage you
need and the courtesy in the end so you
cannot be a preset it but if you choose
it very very small you have a lot of
centroids but they're very high accuracy
but yeah
so usual values are somewhere around
zero dot 0 1 or something like that we
already have a quite high accuracy and
the second part of this capacity is the
value of the quantile times 1 minus the
value of this quantile if you plot this
it looks exactly like this and this is
the magic behind it so what we see is
that the capacity on very small value so
around zero and around one is is very
small this means if we add a new element
in this range as a quantile in this
range then the capacity is quite limited
this means we often have to add a new
centroid which makes yea high accuracy
but if we are around the million area
capacity is quite high and there we can
put a lot of elements into one centroid
and that is where you store in the end
or you save the storage and yet to wrap
this up we have no capacity on extreme
quantized and therefore high accuracy at
extreme quantized and that's exactly
what we are looking for and yeah with
that I would like to finish with the
algorithms last but not least I would
like to announce that we decided to open
source Bob project so we will do that in
the beginning of June so one is the
whole animali project including the
algorithms and so on and the other one
will be a pipe in implementation of TD
chest and yeah feel free to download to
use it to contribute we are looking
forward to that thank you very much
and i think the ecosystem especially
when it comes to monitoring it is very
fragmented and there are a lot of tools
and we had to reinvent the wheel and
when we did this so we think it will be
appreciated by a lot of others as well
because if you're operating at scale and
I would imagine that you would want to
do something like this so I think
overall we feel that it will be useful
to the community and we want people to
contribute more algorithms at the end of
the day so we can improve our system as
well we do use stats d and graphite as
well but this is the very lower end of
the funnel so our metrics flows through
graphite multiple layers of carbon and
one of the endpoints is graphite and
another is animali graphite is just
where you would plot graphs and see as a
developer and anomalies where you would
have in hands off approach as a you know
as an end user and expect the system to
actually detect issues now
solutely not whisper doesn't necessarily
scale and we do use whisper as a back
end to graphite but the metric store
that you saw in the overview for us it's
Redis in this case and I think going by
your talk in the morning we would be we
would like to explore blusky if I'm
right for time series data because it
makes sense sure yeah you can merge
soumya right as possible not yet so it's
at the moment it's still kind of a basic
implementation so there's a reference
implementation by Ted adding in Java but
yeah we'll work on that also adding
different d digest objects yeah yeah
sure okay alright so let's thank again
to be yes cynical
you
you